para tener un mejor entendimiento de
flexibilización cuantitativa en el
contexto americano especialmente en el
contexto del que habla ben bernanke
quiero leer esta cita que dijo 20 blake
en un discurso que dio en la escuela de
economía de londres el día 13 de enero
del 2009 esto se dijo un poco después de
que toda la locura de crisis financiera
ocurriera aunque todavía seguía un poco
el dice nuestra aproximación al cual
puede ser descrita como flexibilización
de crédito se asemeja a flexibilización
cuantitativa en un aspecto entonces él
está diciendo que no es flexibilización
cuantitativa aunque en realidad lo es
implica una expansión de la hoja de
balance del banco central así que solo
para entender lo que de lo que se está
hablando el banco central tiene pasivos
y activos como cualquier otra
corporación y los activos más los
patrimonios deben emparejarse con los
activos pero por simplicidad tengamos a
los activos de los pasivos juntos
digamos que esta es aquí
balance del banco central estos son sus
activos activos y estos sus pasivos
activa pasivos y este es su patrimonio
aunque el patrimonio de la reserva
federal es un poco extraña no es como el
patrimonio tradicional que obtiene todo
el exceso de beneficios todo el exceso
de beneficios aquí va al gobierno de
eeuu pero cuando la reserva federal
imprime dinero lo que hacen literalmente
es crear activos y pasivos de
compensación entonces cuando el primer
dinero digamos que están imprimiendo
dinero aquí en esos supongamos hacemos
de imaginación que el dinero es dinero
que están imprimiendo así que notas de
la reserva federal están siendo creadas
estas son notas que son esencialmente
dólares aquí lo dibujo el dólar siendo
impresos física o electrónicamente
después tienen una compensación de
pasivos que están pendientes están
diciendo estas son notas que nosotros
hemos creado notas pendientes es el otro
lado de la hoja de balance y analizando
el enunciado cuando dice flexibilización
crédito se asemeja a flexibilización
cuantitativa en un aspecto implica una
expansión de la hoja de balance del
banco central esta es la hoja de balance
del banco central aunque es
esencialmente lo mismo que imprimir
dinero luego el banco central hará que
estas notas entren en circulación
saliendo al mercado y comprando activos
comúnmente cuando la reserva federal
está enfocada en tasas de interés a
corto plazo como tasas de préstamos a
corto plazo entre bancos usará estos
para comprar deudas a corto plazo que
incrementarán la cantidad de dinero allá
afuera la cantidad de dólares y baja la
tasa de interés para gente comprando y
vendiendo dólares la bajará o mejor
dicho pidiendo y prestando dólares no
comprando y vendiendo sino pidiendo y
prestando y es que la tasa a corto plazo
de los bancos bajará porque hay más
dólares en las calles y eso es lo que
normalmente preocupa a la reserva
federal y dicen mira flexibilidad
cuantitativa es simplemente esta idea de
expandir la hoja de balance ahora
sigamos leyendo dice como sea en un
régimen de flexibilidad cuantitativa el
enfoque político es la cantidad de
reservas bancarias las cuales son
pasivos del banco central
posición de préstamos y valores en el
lado de los activos de la hoja de
balance del banco central es incidental
lo que se está diciendo es en
flexibilidad cuantitativa tradicional el
banco central dice lo siguiente dicen
bueno mira a mí sólo me importa imprimir
dinero por consiguiente sus pasivos
crecen entonces aquí lo que tenemos son
notas pendientes nuevamente y aquí la
altura es proporcional al dinero impreso
supongamos que este es otro trillón de
dólares que se está imprimiendo es
proporcional la reserva federal- dice
bueno en flexibilidad cuantitativa
tradicional lo que el banco central
quiere es imprimir dinero y sacarlo a
circular a que circule realmente no les
importa el uso del dinero entonces bueno
si saben por supuesto a comprar activos
usualmente activos de tesorería y
después que más dice dice en efecto
aunque el enfoque político del banco de
japón entonces está comparando lo
relativo a lo que hizo japón cuando yo
se toparon con precios deflacionarios
dice en efecto aunque el enfoque
político del banco de japón durante el
período de flexibilización cuantitativa
fue algo multifacético
la orientación general de su política
fue medido ante todo en términos de su
objetivo para reservas bancarias y lo
que esto nos dice es que cuando los
japoneses intentaron terminar con su
crisis deflacionaria siguieron
imprimiendo dinero siguió incrementando
lado de los pasivos de la hoja de
balance siguieron imprimido dinero y si
usaron ese dinero para un montón de
cosas y lo usaron para comprar un montón
de activos pero el enfoque de su
intervención fue la cantidad cuánto
imprimieron realmente a ellos no les
importó a dónde iba ese dinero no no les
importó eso no querían realmente cambiar
lo que ocurría en el mercado donde en
los cuales participaban ahora bueno
sigamos leyendo el discurso en contraste
la aproximación de flexibilización
crediticia de la reserva federal se
enfoca en la combinación de préstamos y
valores que sostiene y como esta
composición de activos afecta a las
condiciones de crédito para el ocupante
de la casa y negocios lo que dice
básicamente es que mecánicamente se está
haciendo lo mismo que japonés o se está
incrementando la hoja de balance lo cual
es análogo a imprimir
pero y también se están comprando un
montón de cosas justo como lo hizo japón
japón tenía una aproximación
multifacética y así es como ponían el
dinero en circulación pero lo que
bernanke dice es que la aproximación no
solamente se enfoca en la cantidad de
dinero que se está imprimiendo no el
enfoque está en donde se está
imprimiendo ese dinero para ser
trabajado es decir cómo se puede usar
ese dinero que fue impreso para
proporcionar liquidez para facilitar las
cosas en ciertas partes de la economía
para entender la oms para entender de lo
que se habla voy a dibujar aquí una
curva una curva de rendimiento aquí
dibuja la curva aquí tenemos en el eje
horizontal vencimiento vencimiento deja
lo escribo vencimiento y acá tenemos
rendimiento rendimiento dibujará la
curva de rendimiento para tesorerías
entonces bueno a los préstamos a corto
plazo para bueno primero voy a hacer
aquí la curva de rendimiento que quizás
se ve algo de esta forma entonces quizás
la tasa de interés a corto plazo ya está
bastante de bastante cerca del cero
aquí tenemos no sé qué porcentaje te
gusta 4% supongamos que
bueno eso nos da una idea entonces esto
es la curva de rendimiento para
tesorerías y también se podría tener una
curva de rendimiento para otras otro
tipo de deudas quizás deuda corporativa
triple-a son deudas muy seguras o deudas
corporativas percibidas pero no son tan
seguras como tesorerías de eeuu entonces
quizás su curva de rendimiento se vea
algo de este estilo algo así se ve su
curva de rendimiento y bueno supongamos
que aquí está a 10 años esta deuda
ok entonces esta diferencia entre esta
deuda corporativa triple-a y la
tesorería esa es la diferencia de
rendimiento y quizás la reserva federal
sea capaz de por intervención primero
imprimir dinero normalmente compran
deudas a corto plazo pero quizás
empiecen a comprar deudas de tesorería a
largo plazo porque quizás eso ayude la
curva de rendimiento de tesorerías a que
baje un poco se ve algo de este estilo
puede pasar que las deudas corporativas
triple-a nos reaccionen y esta
diferencia no se mantenga constante
quizás la diferencia se aumente se
ensanche
por así decirlo quizás estos son títulos
con garantía hipotecaria de alta
calificación tengan una tasa de interés
un poco más alta puede ser y aunque las
tasas de interés en tesorería se estén
bajando mientras intentan bueno porque
todo está toda esta locura que estaba
ocurriendo una economía la diferencia
entre las tesorerías y los títulos de
con garantía hipotecaria o la diferencia
entre tesorerías y las deudas
corporativas triple-a eso aumenta la
diferencia lo puedes ver como como las
tasas de interés en tesorerías
disminuyendo mientras las otras deudas
no lo siguen entonces lo que ben
bernanke dice miren estamos si estamos
haciendo flexibilización cuantitativa si
estamos imprimiendo dinero y estamos
usando este dinero para comprar en la
economía y estamos incrementando la
cantidad de dinero que hay en la
economía pero el objetivo no es
incrementar las reservas porque
realmente no va no va a cambiar el
comportamiento de los de los bancos lo
que hacemos es salir a comprar cosas
como títulos con garantía hipotecaria de
alta calificación o cosas como papel
comercial respaldado deudas corporativas
triple-a para
y esas cosas para que los intereses
bajen obviamente bueno hay gente que
puede estar dispuesta a pagar más por
una cierta cantidad de deuda y bueno
entonces perdonen que él se preocupa más
por lo que termina estando en el lado de
los activos en la hoja de balance ajá
por qué por qué toma dólares impresos
compra otras cosas él pone títulos
respaldados por hipotecas por acá los
pone también pone deudas corporativas
triple-a por acá o también quizás ponga
algunos valores de tesorería a largo
plazo